So how is it that one-third
divided by one-half is two-thirds?
Well, dividing fractions
can also be thought of as
multiplying by the reciprocal.
A reciprocal, this means that you
switch the numerator and denominator,
so the reciprocal of one-half
becomes two over one.
Since dividing is the same thing
as multiplying by the reciprocal,
one-third divided by one-half becomes
one-third times two over one and
we remember from before,
that we just multiply the numerators.
So one times two gives us two and
we multiply the denominators,
three times one gives us three.
Find the reciprocal of these numbers,
two-thirds, fourteen-fifths,
three, one-seventh.
Here's a hint, any whole number is
the same thing as that number over one,
so three is three over one.